what is up reject nation first time in a
while
all these characters in the title and we
are not aptly dressed at
all no fandom in line we usually get
credit for wearing
the shirt that matches appropriately
damn it we have we have failed we've
failed hold on i have a bag full we can
we can all change and i have a closet
full
but we just can't make the i just want
to wear the shirt i
wore today okay i don't want to cheat i
want to express other parts of my family
i want to wear the same shirt i always
wear
my spiderman shirt from target you guys
are going to watch from mighty raccoon
superman versus saitama versus
homelander versus omni man in epic
battle
let's see how they go down today
[Music]
[Music]
that was a good trailer for the trailer
whoa
damn who would win in this fight
think superman and homelander would
definitely have it over omni man
for sure i don't know but omniman's got
the mustache but
one punch man you can't you just can't
defeat that guy
you can with season two
this dude's always so bored
so i'ma take this bald guy over here
and you guys can beat the living hell
out of each other
and after that i'll come to kill both of
you
okay
all right
not impressed
good luck sounds like him
that's what i feel like we're building
too
big subversion you don't want to talk
okay that's better just so you know
it'll be an
honor for you to get your head blasted
by me
the one and only
wow oh damn
that's that's accurate you ain't [ __ ]
homelander that's accurate
oh i like the skin
texture they put on sites in his face
[Music]
i mean superman would beat on me man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is he gone bizarro
[Music]
that's a good reveal
yeah that's about accurate
i honestly i honestly think saturn is
not my favorite but
based off of you know
nice fighter nice fight
that's that's accurate that was very
amusing
like for me i think the rankings of
power would be
i don't know the people who obviously
would get in a big argument over all
this but i think it would
be it'd be saitama
superman omni no superman homelander
omni man i think
that would be the ranking of just the
powers and abilities like saitama
dude never loses right he he just knocks
people out with one punch that's
that's especially yeah he's called one
punch man for a reason superman he's got
the strength the super speed he's got
the laser optic blasts the ability to
freeze things with his breath he's got
multiple powers and homelander which is
like a superman omni man still
he mainly just has super speed and super
strength and like enhanced hearing and
all that so he's got he's got all those
skills but he's missing some but he
can't blast you he can't do the blast or
anything
although i would argue okay let's see
this is what this is
for omni man is he's the most
militant-like
out of any of them more than superman
and more than homelander because of just
the way he was raised and having to
conquer planets and like just sort of
who what his people
are maybe there'd be a little bit more
strategy to him so i think i'm right
about the ranking of
powers but perhaps combat ability and to
assess in a fight
honestly omniman might have the edge
when you throw sights of it in there i
mean you just
i didn't finish i only wat because like
when i was watching one punch man it was
watching it when it was on netflix and
then
season two was on netflix and i didn't
finish season two so i don't know what
the progression is besides him up before
i know about him like you just can't
beat the guy
yeah it seems like it would have to come
down to a saitama victory
regardless yeah and this whole the whole
shape of this
short film from mighty raccoon reflects
that in the perspective of saitama
everyone's all aggressive and ready for
a big battle and he shows up with
groceries and drops and is just like oh
i guess i'm in a fight
like he's just so ambivalent towards
everything and so detached and bored
with life that's
like that's his character yeah and then
like while they're having their big
battle omni man and superman
like when they're having their big
battle omni man and superman and the way
that reveal was done was great because
it looks like omni man has
his hand over here like wait a minute
did i
totally miss or understand what just
happened here and then you they did the
reveal back and you realize
it's it's it's satuma who has his hands
on both of them which is great yeah well
i'm just starting off too with
homelander like running his mouth like
it
this was structured kind of in the
perfect way because yeah i mean he's
obviously going to be the most sort of
brash and talkative and then yeah to
have that reveal of like you
you get this build up of a scene and
then saitama just just
like scores him in a similar style like
you could imagine homeland or goring
someone in the boys and then he had to
have that reveal come back around if
like we shift the focus to omni man and
superman and then have you know this
this great like it is a great little
subtle visual mislead
yeah you get the close-up hand and then
you all you gets the sleeve and then you
know oh damn
and then the timing of him just cracking
their heads off is
beautiful and so yeah it was like a
subversion almost i really thought this
was really fun to watch
another mighty raccoon they take their
time to put their videos together
because these take a lot of work
so kudos again to another successful
video another great video from
the team over at mighty raccoon guys
always knock it out of the party all
right guys well
who do you think would have win in a
fight like this who do you wish won in
this mighty raccoon fight leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button last but not
least let's do a
everett baker i'm adding you to the
fight
because man i don't know what you look
like so to my mind ever baker it's all
potential buddy
think of it i'm imagining you maybe not
as the buffest hero
but as one who has cunning who has a
complex
array of physical powers like super
human
taste super human uh predictability
uh in terms of like being able to
predict what other people are gonna say
so like you know if somebody forgets
their train of thought you could pick it
up for them
and then think of what that could bring
to a fight like this i mean
everett baker putting laying down the
bacon
think of your catchphrases my dude it's
time to get
baked think of all the cool things you
could say before smushing someone's head
all right that's great let's redo this
oh that's good uh okay
everett baker